you say kikuchi going through his
warm-up tosses if you say is anywhere
near the pitcher we saw his last time
out last saturday here at home against
the oakland a's he's going to have a
good ball game charlie blackman
advancing to the plate now and what a
start for the rockies
all-star right fielder working on a
10-game hitting streak right now
swinging a chopper to the left side
taken by d gordon and the long throw to
first base and it's going to be in time
to give blackman no one was at second it
took
long a long time to get the second base
so in its second goes hampson
blackman is out at first base 6-3
so a two-out run scoring opportunity for
nolan arenado swinging a ground ball is
short gordon to his left he's got it the
throw to first and it's in time to get
aronado and that'll end the inning
antonio centella making his third start
of the year he's 2-0 so two on and two
outs bottom of any number one and
that'll bring up catcher austin nola
ground ball right side right at the
second baseman ryan mcmahon he throws it
to first and antonio works out of
trouble a rise smile on his face as he
departs the field mariner's nothing the
rockies nothing and here is shortstop d
gordon
on the ground to trevor that it's a low
throw and that's the fourth error on
trevor story throw to second is high
look out d gordon ran into the second
base umpire corey blazer looked like
trev just never got a handle on the ball
yeah and then he just threw it down down
the line towards home plate and daniel
murphy could not stretch back and pull
it in and here is right fielder malik
smith and the mariners again have a base
runner in scoring position now the 1-1
pitch swinging a line drive base in left
field d-roddy third being waved in by
maniac to up with the ball is hamson the
throw to the plate off the glove of
arenado alex smith will wind up on its
second base with a single and a run
batter then the mariners have a
one-nothing lead and malix takes second
on the throw hole it's good to see the
mariners take advantage of a mistake so
diaz at second owings at third for
garrett hampson swinging a bouncer off
the glove of kikuchi the shortstop near
the bag will throw hampson out the
runner scores from third and the rockies
tie the game at one as chris owings
scoots home so here's trevor story with
one out and a runner at third now in a
one-one game fastball swung on grounded
to the left side runner break seegers
throw home the slide not in time getting
the left hand in was diaz and the
rockies lead at two to one on the
aggressive base running by the rockies
catcher and here's charlie blackmon
swing in a line drive center field and
that'll bounce for a base hit an 11-game
hitting streak for charlie blackmon now
just a great beginning for the rockies
all-star here's daniel vogelback the d-h
fly ball to left field and down the line
on the run as hampson hampson reaches
out and makes the catch and toward the
corner two outs in the inning garrett
hampson had a lot of ground to cover and
he gets there in time down the left
field line vogee going the other way
flies out ty and run at third and malik
smith dylan looking for his first hit of
the night he's flat out to right and
senzatella struck him out breaking ball
swang and a miss he got him with the
curveball big punch out for senzatella
he strands a runner in third hopefully
daniel murphy can come through here with
two outs runners at second and third
brown ball right side and into right
field for a base hit blackman scores
kemp scores and the rockies lead it 4-1
diving try by shed long he couldn't get
it in short right field daniel murphy
with two more rbis a scoring opportunity
for seattle now and right-handed hitting
austin nola the catcher who has been
very good in these run scoring
situations hard contact speaking of it
out to left and gone home run austin
nola
number one in 2020 with a punch
first home run sends cinzantella's given
up this season
now the mariners are within one two outs
in the rocky seventh hampson a walk an
rbi groundout swing and a high fly ball
deep left center field back she goes and
go on
garrett hampson
muscles up and sends one over and out
and it's now 5-3 rockets charlie's had a
good night with two singles and a run
scored he drives a ball to deep right
field and it's out of here charlie
blackmon touch him all time rockies with
homers in back-to-back innings they lead
it 6-3 and the rockies have a man on
brings our first baseman daniel murphy
this ball hammered to right this one's
gonna fly rocky's playing low ball in
seattle it's eight to three now
back to back ball games for burp hitting
the seats one aboard that'll bring up
catcher austin nola he's swinging a
ground ball fair inside the bag at first
and down the right field line lewis off
to the races rounding second heading for
third gonna be waved in up with the ball
is blackman the throw in cut off by
murphy the relay to the plate not in
time kyle lewis will score austin nola
in at second base with a two-out rbi
double
it's now the rockies eight and the
mariners four for austin nola two outs
more
oh for four three strikeouts he's got
him see you later and for the third time
in rocky's history they are ten and
three or better to begin a season